[Music]
introducing Dr Blac Chyna I had to like
come out show out you know the surprises
keep coming from the model who revealed
on Instagram Monday that she received a
doctorate of liberal arts degree from
Sacramento Theological Seminary and
Bible College earlier this year China
whose real name is Angela White shared
this snap of her certificate next to a
photo of her kids ten-year-old King
Cairo whom she shares with her ex Tyga
and six-year-old dream whom she shares
with another ex Rob Kardashian according
to its website
stsbc is a home study and on-campus
Bible College and Seminary specializing
in education for working pastors working
people and church members its doctoral
program explores the Old Testament New
Testament biblical languages and
backgrounds of the biblical era I'm
doing good I'm just feeling blessed
right now this all comes after China was
baptized last year and in the name of
the Holy Ghost this vulnerability that
we're seeing in the desire to talk you
say it's Faith thank you in your words
found God was Faith a part of your
journey before now no this was my first
time ever being baptized
China announced she got rid of her only
fans page which has reportedly made her
hundreds of millions of dollars you get
booked for clubs you get booked for
videos you get booked for appearances
are you going to lose money
I've been stopped a lot of this stuff
and China's been documenting what she
calls a life-changing Journey on social
media reversing the Cosmetic work she
had done on her breasts and backside one
of the best decisions I could have done
in a very long time
she also dissolved the fillers from her
face it like totally changed my face and
I'm just I'm ready to get back to Angela
and she shared the process of having a
demonic tattoo removed from her hip it
got to come off I just don't want
anything negative or demonic on my body
anymore of course this all comes after
China sued members of her ex's famous
family the Kardashians for defamation
But ultimately lost the case in May
2022. the mother of my brother's
daughter is suing me Kylie Kimberly and
my mom for defamation and interference
with the contract she is saying that the
Rob and China show
didn't get a second season because we
interfered with it not because they
weren't in a relationship anymore
the trial was discussed on the famous
family's Hulu series and cameras were
rolling as they received the verdict
what happened we won
but now China seems to have turned a
corner we have to really dig deep and
figure out like who it is that we are so
is this new and improved version of
China ready for new love earlier this
week she sat down with Sirius xm's Sway
in the morning and said right now she's
just focused on bettering herself and
I'm not worried about that right now or
about me
like it's all about me amen you feel me
and I like that I like that a lot
actually
[Music]
foreign